walter's going to narrate the film as we
play it
the first picture you start out at the
power plant
which is uh some of the buildings
connected to the laundry building
this is
aerial view
from the top of the mountain
of the whole camp
this is another view taken
an aerial view it's some of the dixon
cottages
cottages in the chapel
in the background
these were
designed by
dr dixon
dr dickson
he was dr dixon was the first
director of health pennsylvania
this is more aerial view of the
surrounding
mountains
shows the
background
of this whole area
this section is the golf course which
was built by the health department
was the golf course for patients
for staff
golf courses for staff and employees
this is still more of the aerial view
there's a closer picture of the golf
course area
these pictures were taken from the snowy
mountain fire tower
which would be south of the sanatorium
that picture was in the cemetery
is this where patients were buried
patients were buried here
this is the
children's hospital
it was originally for patients
that were
too sick to be
taking care of themselves and
during world war one
up until 1923
it was filled by veterans of world war
one that had been gassed in the service
then in 1924 why they children removed
him
that building was the infirmary
well
these are open-air pavilions on the main
hospital grounds
beside all these cottages there was 56
of this type of cottages you decided
in these one of these cottages was open
air pavilions with
chairs that patients sat in for hours
and hours
were the coverages heated
the cottages had steam heat
in the center out of the cottage
in the hallway there wasn't any heat in
the rooms unless you had the door open
this is nurses from the nurses training
we ran from 1924 to 1935.
they had a two-year training course
for nurses to be trained for tb
patients
this is a store that's on the
main grounds
where supplies could be
newspapers
anything
along that line if they need stationary
anything along that line could be bought
at the store
for the patient for the patient this is
the chapel built in 1911.
this was the original
one of the first nurses home
buildings
later on it was used as
office buildings
this was the first
large dining room
and these are all patients that are
bathing in the sun fresh air and
sunlight
are male and female segregated
yes there was an upper what they called
upper lower men's camp and it was an
upper lower women's camp
they were different
in which section what is that man doing
there
he is probably
the uh
either a doctor or
an age that's just
supervise and
make sure that everybody is getting
sunned and
keep in order really
we examined the patients
regular they would be open
and doctors would examine
them to make sure
that
everything that was possible at that
time could be done
for them
these patients
who are holding mirrors
with the sunlight at their back shining
in the mirror and the light goes into
their mouth too
it was a way that they felt would
cure their throats
go up their throats with the sunlight
and this was the assembly building that
had been used for a theater it was
theater and also there was a school
a business training school
and
that building had burnt
and then
about two years later there was a new
building
to replace that one
and there's a lot of deer in the area
and some of them would get tame
come right in around the cottages
this would be at the moment a train
station that would be about five miles
from here at the front of the mountain
these were
children that they'd bring in here in
the summer
mostly from the cities they were called
fresh air children
and they would stay
in a building back of the children's
hospital it was a long building
back at the children's hospital
screened on the sides
and they would stay there for the summer
months
and
just uh
felt the fresh air and the
good food would
be a help for them
everybody was
brought up in trucks from the train
station to the top of the mountain
then the children were all examined when
they come in to check for any diseases
so that
it wouldn't start a
epidemic for the whole area everybody
was tested
and received a few shots which they
didn't care for
all these tests were made before these
children were put in with any of the
other
any other children
everybody received a complete haircut
what was the reason for the haircut
uh the haircut was
because some of the children had
had lice when they came or other
skin diseases and they could they could
check for this and treat it immediately
this is in the bath
houses everybody had their own
toothbrush that they kept with them and
there was a
there was containers in there that had a
tooth powder and you just went to the
container put powder on your brush
and was one container for everyone uh
there would be
containers there would probably be
a dozen of these containers to each
bath house you just held the brush
underneath you push the button and the
powder came down onto the brush
and here they're just examining the
children as they can
looking to see what
for condition they're in
all clothing
except your shoes
were and socks were supplied by the
state
all cleaning was flat you you brought
your own shoes
and
you uh
if you had any repair on your shoes
why that
uh you had to pay for the repair of your
shoes
and your own stock and everything else
was supplied by the state
you paid for your own haircuts and your
shoe repair
some of these children are
very thin when they came
because the food and the fresh air here
did have a way of
fattening you pretty quick
this is the
was twice the day
this was
milk
and the cans
one of the men from the dining room
would bring out the milk you you went
through you picked up your
your cup
filled it and then there was a container
you put the cups in they were taken back
and washed and then you'd be ready for
the next
time that the milk cart came around
milk was
bought by the state from local
farmers in this area and
had their own
pasteurizing
plant here and
of course all the milk was in
refrigeration and it was cool
these are the
children of the sunbathing
and a cloth over their face was
just to keep the sun out of their other
face and their eyes
and
they would lay so long in the one way
and then they would turn and
they that
you gradually got a suntan without
getting sunburned
nurses doctors who would watch some
people
burn much easier in other ones and
some could only be out a short time
there was a lot of swings
see-saw sliding boards
and this building was located on a hill
and in the winter time
there was probably
2 300 sleds
there for sliding
but you were out every day
unless you were real sick
real bad cold or something you were out
every day
is
shown
in one of the uh
rooms
and
everybody makes their own bed and
they're ready for inspection
as the nurse and the doctors come
through
check everyone
because anyone feels bad that day this
is when you tell them and you're taking
them to the clinic
check the hands the fingernails
and make sure you're washed and make
sure you
have your your hands clean
and check your beds to make sure the bed
is made properly
there's
probably 20 beds to reward
as you notice the children all saluted
when the doctor and the nurse left
and when they entered
in this building the
boys were all on the second floor
and the girls were on the first floor
and at the north end of this building
was an auditorium which was used for a
for chapel for
a theater
anything of that type
now on the second floor was
classrooms
these children were all still in school
and you went to school a half day
four day or five days a week half day at
a time
you had practically the same classes
that you would have had in schools at
home
is
these are more tests
that's given regular
to make sure that everyone is okay
so
besides all the
swings
and the playground equipment there was
boy scouts
girl scouts
there was movies
religious services
every weekend
one of the punishments if if you didn't
do
everything that you were expected to do
or if you were a troublemaker one of
your punishments was you didn't get to
go to the saturday
afternoon movie you had to stay in bed
while the movie was on
that seemed to be
harder on most people and almost any
other punishment they could have
received
another thing for the girls was sewing
classes
they were taught to make their own
clothing for doll babies
it was a lot of organizations
not toys
and uh doll babies and
all kinds of toys in there at christmas
time it was given october
everybody received a prize there was
a lot of games brought in
by different organizations
and these were things
games that you had
for play
marbles with another
it's a lot of marbles
everything was along that line was
furnished by different organizations
so
and this was every eating everyone had
their temperature taken
and that was recorded
this was in the area of
the
sick
sick awards it wasn't
so much so in
in the other part of the hospital
the hospital would hold
240 patients
and most of the time it was failed
it was started in 19
first children came in from hamburg
pennsylvania in 1924
that was mostly a way to settle
arguments you got a chance to put the
boxing gloves on
but they made sure no one got hurt too
bad
even the girls like the boxing gloves
this is more in the playground area
these are all still the fresh air kids
none of the real
none of the children have had
tuberculosis
no there isn't any tuberculosis children
in this
in this area now there was children
in the main
children's hospital
that would be there for
maybe a couple years two three years
until they got
better but
what they called the fresh air child
were only brought in through the summer
months they'd be here about three months
and then they went back
if some of them were obeying them
then they would be kept in the main
hospital
and they would stay there until they
were able to go home
this hospital
right here was closed in
january 1940
that at that time they were moved
closer to the main
hospital into a new building which had
been built in 1938-39
and
on later
years why
this building
was completely torn down this pool was
inside
yes
and these were inside pools
1936 there was a another section built
to this
building for
polio patients
and
they had
hot baths
massage tables it's like that in there
for the polio
children but when the
children moved from this building to the
new building in 1940
the
polio award
was
moved somewhere else i don't know where
it was moved to
but those children didn't come over to
the new building
almost everybody
preferred the old building
over the new
you were watched too close in the new
building
we had more fun at the other place
so you were there during that transition
yes i was i was there and moved into the
near valley
but they do put
put weight on you with
extra
good meals
and health and
everything i came here i weighed
76 pounds i left i weighed 114.
well this is in the winter and
sliding area
and you could slide for a long distance
down that yeah there were a few trees
you had to watch but there was a long
distance you could slide clear down
but it's all grown up now but you could
go clear down to the main road
at the hospital
but regardless of the weather you were
out and every day
you did bring your own top coats that
was one thing you you furnished your own
top chart
with many snowball bottles
from the classrooms which was above the
auditorium all these children were in
school
and you went to school a half four five
days a week a half day at a time
and
the classroom was
above the auditorium and it was so close
the mountain you could look right out
the window and see deer
walking around
right up from the building
so
again we're back to the melt line
that man that's running the milk line is
a neighbor of mine right now
he worked for the hospital at that time
and you were taken on
on hikes
you're right camping a lot of times you
would take a little
bag of food
if you were gonna be out close to a meal
time and everybody had their own picnic
lunch with them
you could walk the road without much
trouble at that time there wasn't
traffic like there is today and
i just walked the main roads
this is a co-ed activity those boys and
girls yeah on this would be yes
both boys and girls would be on this
you were taught how to make your own bed
we'd be clean linen twice a week
or more if it was necessary
these are different nurses
there was a nurse's home built right to
the south of the main of this main
children's hospital
they had their own nurses home building
right there
this hospital had its own power plant in
its own
kitchen dining room
even the nurses like to use the swings
did the nurses stay for a long time or
was there a lot of turnover
where they would quit new ones come in
or become ill
a lot of nurses stayed
they would marry other employees here
and
lived here there's a lot of the nurses
still that came here as nurses married
somebody and still live here in the area
there was a lot of patience
came here when they were cured
they went to the nurses training course
that had hair
on grounds and then they stayed here as
nurses some went to other
tuberculosis hospitals throughout the
state to nurse but a lot of them stayed
here
and like i said a lot of them still live
here came from different parts of the
state and
they still live here in the area
are these girls are boys
that's probably
probably girls and boys both there
girls would run around without tops
uh no
the girls would have had would have tops
uh
this is one of the
the buses
they had at that time that they would
take
children for rides
some of these are leaving been here for
the summer some of these are leaving
going back
they go to mornata
which is five miles down the mountain
from here they get a train
from there
to hagerstown and then from hagerstown
they will take another train
to philadelphia washington baltimore
worst would be
most that came in here would be from
pennsylvania there would be some from
other states but most always from
pennsylvania
and when you went out on walks you
lined up
sort of a military style and
everybody traveled together
racing of the flag
every morning eating
when the flag went up or the flight come
down you you were out
through raising the roaring of the flag
there's a lot of different little
activities like that was
to
keep to keep you your mind occupied keep
you out of
other troubles
all appear to be dressed up
these these are
these are children that are leaving
they've been here for the summer and
they're leaving and going
back home
we're getting on
boarding the train right now
now people
that came here like myself that lived
i only lived about 40 miles from here
my my parents brought me and then they
came and picked me up and took me
took me
home that appears to be the end of the
season yes
you